so today I want to tell you about two
things that are related beri numbers and
FH habber fabulous
formula so when I was a kid I kept a
journal and I also had a math journal
where I kept all my secret private
musings about math when I got to
Princeton I asked one of my professors
my first year in college um about a
question that I was looking at in my
journal and she said I don't know the
answer to that but you should go talk to
this guy John Conway you might have
heard of him I actually only barely knew
who he was at the time so you weren't
like oh my God John Conway I had just
had a vague idea yeah yeah which was
probably good so I went home and emailed
him and uh he said come talk to me I
brought him my journal he looked at some
of the things I'd written in there which
was very kind of him and then he told me
about bobber's fabulous formula and the
bruli numbers and that actually uh led
to what I work on in research today in
an active area of mathematical research
in number Theory so you were introduced
to these things by John Conway himself
amazing yes do you do you remember the
day uh I do and in my regular Journal I
journaled about it I was in the spring
of 1999 I'd have to look up the precise
day but it was a beautiful spring day in
1999 where did we start we're going to
ask ask a few questions about sums of
numbers so what is the value of 1 to the
K plus 2 to the K plus 3 to the K plus
dot dot dot plus n the k for K some
positive whole number and um just to
make sure we're on the same page so for
example if n equal 100 and k equals say
2 we're looking at 1 2ar + 2 2ar + 3 2ar
plus dot dot dot dot dot
plus 100 squared and uh so on so if K is
zero this is really easy because we've
got 1 to the 0 plus 2 to the 0 + 3 to
the 0 plus d d d it's just 1 + 1 plus do
do dot + 1 n * so we get
n if we look at first Powers then we
have 1 + 2+ 3 plus d dot dot dot plus n
and there's a formula for this which
people sometimes learn in school uh you
might know how to prove it there's also
a proof on number file in some previous
episode and so this is often written as
n * n + 1 over 2 so we could compute
this guy easily now what if you want to
work with squares or cubes so what about
this number from before so we had these
squares do do dot dot plus N2 equals or
cubes or fourth powers and so on so the
question becomes what are these numbers
how can we get it and uh you can't just
if you try to just generalize the
approach in that other number file video
from this guy and you're like okay I
understand that so got good intuition
I'll try to do that for squares you
might be able to push things a little
further but once you get to cubes and
beyond that kind of trick is going to
become out just a mess so do we have
more
paper so this is where fou hub's
fabulous formula and the bruli numbers
come into play so is the fabulous
formula what is going to solve that
problem for us it is yeah yeah it's a
formula that solves it yeah bhober said
Okay I want to look at one to the K -1 +
2 to the K -1 + 3 to the K -1 Plus do
dot dot dot plus n the
K-1 that's equal
to 1 /
K times um I'm going to put something in
quotes right now and then I'll explain
it because well there's two reasons it's
going to be in quotes so we're going to
look at n + B to the K so we've gone
down one here and up here minus B to the
K and I haven't told you what this B is
here you know n is it's our whole number
U these B's are going to tie into the uh
bruli numbers this is going to be I'll
have to tell you what the stuff on the
right hand side is but this is f hub's
fabulous
formula I'm assuming fhab themself isn't
the person who called it the fabulous
formula uh no and I'm not sure how it
originated uh certainly John Conway
called it that and but you you would
want I don't know whether it's safe to
attribute to John Conway he and Richard
guy in their book do you know the Book
of Numbers they write about this in the
Book of Numbers certainly sounds like a
John Conway ISM so I'm going to have to
tell you about these be of the ks these
be's are going to behave in a way that
usually would be quite quite weird okay
so how to define B to the K now first of
all I'm going to define a number B zero
with the look we have a subscript here
this is
one and I'm going that's a definition
there and I'm going to Define
B subscript k equals b superscript k
this looks terrible looks like I took a
power or something and then I just used
a superscript I still have to tell you
about this guy though and then for K
greater than one we're going to put
B min-1 to the k equal B to the K this
is a rule and we're going to use this to
Define all the other B subk So
eventually things are going to drop down
here a Bly numbers uh the B sub K oh yes
and these are the broli numbers okay
cool just checking yes this is the Casi
bruli number okay cool let's compute
what B1 is since all we know so far is
the value of b0 so if we want to do that
we'll use this rule we have b - 1^ 2 =
b^2 so doing this I get b^2 minus 2 b +
1 equal 0 just skipping the step of
canceling the B squs and so this tells
me then B1 equals 12 and remember we
drop our subscript down so this becomes
the first berol number so this is our
first boli number the value is a half
you can continue like this you can keep
Computing these right so if you should I
do another example let's see the next
one okay so now let's find B2 so for
that we have to raise now to the third
power and the B cubes are going to
cancel again and then I have - 3 B2 + 3
B1 - 1 = 0 having just canceled the B
cubes already and I know what B1 is
because we just figured that out that's
a half and so now I have
um3 and I'll just drop my subscripts
down since I know I can do that from my
rule equals uh 1us 3 * a half since we
just figured out that this guy is a half
so we have over here 1 - 3 Hales minus a
half great so B2 equals 1 16 okay all
I'm not going to keep doing examples all
day all right so we get a whole bunch of
B numbers yeah we get a whole bunch of
them yeah so now we've computed a bunch
of bees and I assert uh following what
felhaber told us I assert that we get
this formula so you can expand this out
and plug in the B sub case I just want
to say a little bit about where this
comes from so just to make sure we see
what's going on in an example we're
going to do this with a small value of K
so if I want to know what 1 2ar + 2 2
plus dot dot dot dot plus say we care
about and we just want to go up to 100
um squared is then what this formula
says is okay our K our K here uh this is
this is K minus one here on the left
hand side we one to the Kus one so that
tells us K must be three so we have one
over three here and then we have our n
is this guy so that's 100 plus b cubed
minus B Cubed and we're just in this
little example going to expand what this
looks like 100 + B cubed minus B Cubed =
3 b ^ 2 * 100 + 3 B1 * 100 2ar + 100
cubed and then I have a B Cubed here
that cancels this B cub Cub so um this
is what we get and then we say up I'm
going to drop these guys down so I have
3 * um
B2 * 100 + 3 B1 * 100 SAR + 100 cubed
and if you car to compute this you can
plug these in because conveniently uh
you just have me compute B1 and B2 so we
could even plug these in here so now
we've got three
* 16 * 100 + 3 * 12 * 100 sared + 100
cubed and you can compute this big
number if you want so now I'm going to
just tell you a little bit about where
this fabulous formula comes from so
let's look first at a slightly different
expression n + B to the
K minus I'm going to subtract off n
+
B-1 to the K and when I do this well
remember we had
this rule here so we had this thing and
so what I do this I'm going to get this
PO using the binomial theorem I'm going
to get this polinomial looks almost the
same on each side except we have a
different powers of of B and powers of B
minus one there and when I unfold this
whole thing I get J equal 0 to k k
choose J N to the J and then I end up
with over here B to the K minus J minus
B minus1 to the K minus J and if I look
back most of these gu most of these
terms are going to be zero because I
have B minus one to a power equals B to
a power and here I'm comparing B minus
one to a power uh with B to a power
except for this rule only holds for K
greater than one and so what we're going
to be left with at the end when we work
through this is um K * n to the K minus
one okay so we unfold this we got a
bunch of zeros except preceding the term
n the K minus1 and there we preceded by
1 * K and so we were left with this and
so now when I want to get bobber's
fabulous formula I have that uh well
first first of all we've just seen that
what this tells us is that n the
kus1 equal 1 K * n + B to the K - n + b
- 1 to the K but I want a whole sum I
don't just want one term here so what I
do is now I'm going to if I want to add
up all the terms so if I want to look at
n the k + 1 + n -1 to the K -1 plus dot
dot dot dot all the way down to 2 to the
K -1 + 1 to the K -1 I'm going to have
to add up 1 over K times now I have n +
B to the K - n + b - 1 to the K that
just takes care of the end of the K
minus one
term plus I have n minus1 + B to
the K minus
just to deal with the next term n -1 + B
-1 to the K and then I get to the next
term which is the n minus 2 term which
is going to go here N - 2 + B to the K
minus nus 2 + B -1 to the K plus D D D D
D D dot until I get to the end where I
look at the one piece and that's going
to give me an one 1 + B to the K - 1 +
B- 1 to the K so this first piece is our
n + B of the K that we have at the
beginning of fh's fabulous Formula 1
plus B minus 1 this is equal to B to the
K and everything in between is going to
cancel because they have n plus B minus
1 or n minus 1 plus b addition uh
commutes so these cancel now I have n
minus 2 and up here I have two * -1 so
that's going to cancel and so on and we
can keep playing this game until at the
end all we're left with is 1 / K times
at the end of the day we get our n + B
to the K minus B to the K and we get fou
hobbers fabulous formula so I've skipped
over a few details but people who are
interested can also uh check those and
that's bobber's fabulous formula and the
broli numbers and one thing that's
really cool with these bruli numbers is
they show up in lots of places you might
have seen them defined in other ways
they show up in Oilers formula for
values of the reman zeta function at
positive even integers and those numbers
there are also encoding uh really deep
information from number Theory which is
the field I work in and so one of the
reasons I really like these is they're
not only convenient in solving this cute
problem is that they tie to really deep
um mathematical
phenomena it was so nice not worrying
anymore that I thought I'm not going to
worry anymore ever again I was going to
study whatever I thought was interesting
and not worry whether this was serious
enough because you know you've got one
two at the end of it next time here
you've got maybe it's two twos I don't
know but anyway it will be twos so the
the left hand sequence
always ends in a two and the right hand
sequence well look it goes one one 1 3
one two